all right so i have a a perfect video
clip for you today
to illustrate one of the biggest ruses
that exists on fox news in the past
when fox news has been criticized for
their outrageous cartoonish right-wing
political bias
they'll often say listen we have our
opinion programming just like any other
network and sure
some of it is is right-wing it's
conservative it's pro-republican
but we are also a news station and
during
news hours we are right up there with
the best of them and reporting
just the facts just the news now without
even looking at today's clip which i'm
going to get to in a moment
understand that fox news deliberately
has blurred
the lines between news and opinion for a
very long time for as long as they've
existed and also not that this is their
fault
due to terrible media literacy in the
united states much of their audience
doesn't realize what is news and what is
opinion
fox news also does something where they
will report on what their opinion hosts
say during the news hours as if it's
news
so tucker carlson one night might say
something insane
on his 9 p.m show and then the next day
the news hours will have
a news report about
tucker carlson said this here's a panel
to discuss it
so even they are able to take their own
opinion programming
and put it directly into the news
segments
so this news versus opinion distinction
has been nonsense from day
from day one but then we have this clip
to play
of news reporter bill hemmer
from the news reporting side of fox news
during a news not opinion show called
america's newsroom saying
we've got to be careful with this cancel
culture stuff because the next thing you
know they're going to cancel
bible characters take a look at the
video clip
i tell you if they start canceling these
american presidents they're going to
come after bible
characters next yeah you could you could
mark my words
right an ominous warning from bill
hemmer
that the cancel culture liberals are
going to cancel
bible characters if we allow them to
continue
for some reason the inclusion of mark my
words at the end
is particularly hysterical i was sort of
chuckling to myself
because as ridiculous and silly as this
is at least bill hemmer is calling them
bible
characters rather than historical
figures now i don't know if that's his
intention
i don't know if we can read too much
into his perspective from it but it is
funny and
this is lowest common denominator type
stuff
this is what happens when you aren't a
victim
and your audience aren't victims at
least in the ways they claim to be much
of the fox news audience are victims
of deficits to our educational system
victims of the power of elites and
corporations and so
okay fine but they're not victims in the
ways they claim to be victims
and the political interests that they
represent
aren't victims either they invent a new
victimhood
the war on christmas was the fabrication
of victimhood
donald trump as the most unfairly
treated person in the world or whatever
it was he claimed to be
that's fabricating victimhood with trump
it was almost like fabricating martyrdom
even and then the saddest most
horrifying part of it
is that a significant portion of the
country i don't know the percentage but
it's it's a significant number
sees this and says yep that resonates
with me
that's a concern of mine that's the
battle that's my battle
that fox news is waging here that feels
like something really important they
might
cancel bible characters uh and it
ends up being the horrible situation
that we have of course
the entire cancellation meme that they
won't stop with
is as pathetic as any specific example
but they've started to get attention
with the cancel culture stuff and so
they're going to ride it
for as long as they can let's do our
best not to fall for it there are some
people on the left
who fall for the cancel culture stuff
and of course
we can all find instances of
wrongful termination or misapplication
of terms of service on a platform
but let's not feed into this false
notion that everything is just unfairly
canceling conservatives who merely want
to
get their opinions out there no we've
talked about it before i'm glad to
rehash it again if necessary
that is not what is going on here we
shouldn't allow ourselves
to feed the notion because they will
just take it and
this is what you end up with i'll tell
you they're going to cancel bible
characters if we let them keep doing it
no
it's not happening